heute geht es um ein richtiges survival
gemüse ganz ehrlich wenn das überleben
meiner familie von einer pflanze
abhängen würde dann würde ich garantiert
dieses gemüse in meinem garten anbauen
ihr wisst ja dass ich versuche möglichst
viel von dem was meine familie ist
selber anzubauen und eine pflanze ist
was das angeht ziemlich unschlagbar und
vor allem ist diese pflanze absolut und
kaputt zwar ich bin mir ziemlich sicher
dass du immer noch genug ernten solltest
auch wenn wir alles daran setzen würde
diese pflanze wieder aus seinem garten
loszuwerden wir waren letzte woche im
schwarzwald da sind wir vor fünf jahren
weggezogen oder jetzt eigentlich bald
schon sechs jahren und vor sieben jahren
habe ich da diese mysteriöse pflanze
gepflanzt und natürlich ist die immer
noch da und das war total schön die zu
besuchen
das war ganz erstaunlich zu sehen dass
da obwohl wir ja schon seit fünf jahren
nicht mehr da waren sich seit fünf
jahren niemand mehr um dieses beet
gekümmert hat und die nachmieter
tatsächlich mehrmals im jahr mit dem
rasenmäher einfach drüberfahren und
alles kurz und klein schneiden dass wir
da trotzdem immer noch richtig viel
ernten konnten das ist unser alter
garten und jetzt schauen wir mal was
unsere wunderpflanze macht da der boden
ist also immer noch voll von dicken
knollen und wahrscheinlich haben die
meisten von euch jetzt auch erraten und
welche pflanze es sich hier handelt sie
hat wunderschöne gelbe blüten aber die
wahren schätze liegen unter der erde
vergraben
richtig es handelt sich hier um den
topinambur man kann den sowohl roh essen
als auch zum kochen verwenden zb den
brei draus machen oder die raspeln und
anbraten oder in scheiben schneiden aber
die schmecken roh auch ziemlich lecker
sind auch super gesund gerade für
diabetiker super geeignet gesagt das ist
eine ziemlich tolle knolle es gibt aber
eine sache die du unbedingt wissen
solltest bevor du topinambur in deinem
garten anbau ist topinambur ist so
hartnäckig und so ausdauernd dass du
wirklich darauf aufpassen solltest du
den in deinem garten hin pflanzt weil er
sich im zweifel über den ganzen garten
ausbreiten kann weil du den sonst nicht
wieder los willst sonst wächst haben
noch überall die einzige chance die man
so hat falls die topinambur wieder
loswerden wollt ist dass man ihn immer
wieder atmet also wirklich immer sobald
die pflanzen rauskommen abnehmen sodass
sie sich auspowern weil sie
sonnen energie tanken können und immer
sofort abgeschaltet werden sobald die
ein bisschen photosynthese fläche haben
eigentlich sollte es gar nicht so weit
kommen deswegen überlegt euch gut wo ihr
topinambur pflanzt und dann immer schön
mit wurzel sperren arbeiten oder den
gleichen coup in anbauen wie du den
topinambur anbaus darüber sprechen wir
gleich noch aber überlegen wir mal kurz
was nach den eigentlich so toll also
warum ist das so eine wertvolle pflanze
wenn es um die selbstversorgung geht das
liegt an der tatsache dass man ihn
einmal pflanzt und immer wieder erntet
jahr für jahr muss keine arbeit mehr
einstecken und kann einfach immer wieder
von der ernte profitieren und das geht
mit ganz vielen mehrjährigen pflanzen
die auch in der permakultur super
wichtig sind da gibt es so viele tolle
pflanzen die man einer pflanze man
einmal arbeit rein steckt und dann jahr
für jahr von denen ernten kann kräuter
beerensträucher spargel walnüsse
haselnuss ist kiwi bern hat die schatten
und räume bei der sache gibt es nur
einen kleinen haken es dauert immer
seine zeit bis die mehrjährigen pflanzen
überhaupt ertrag abwerfen deswegen sage
ich immer leute pflanzen die einen neuen
garten hat als allererstes die
mehrjährigen pflanzen und danach erst
den einjährigen gemüseladen vielleicht
könnte er den spruch die beste zeit
einen baum zu pflanzen war vor 20 jahren
die zweitbeste zeit ist jetzt aber
zurück zum topinambur wo bekommt man die
knollen her wenn man die jetzt pflanzen
will
am einfachsten ist es wenn du einfach im
bioladen gehst und da schaust oder auch
mal im edeka gibt es sie auch manchmal
einfach mal in verschiedene supermärkte
gehen und die da kaufen da kann man
einfach dann die knollen bei sich zu
hause im garten einpflanzen man kann den
topinambur jetzt im frühling pflanzen
oder dann wieder im herbst die sache ist
nur dass die garten händler also wenn
man richtigen pflanzen in hamburg in der
gärtnerei kaufen möchte dass die
meistens nur im frühling welchen haben
das heißt wenn ihr richtigen pflanze
topinambur kaufen möchte und nicht den
aus dem bioladen verwenden wollt dann
wäre jetzt der zeitpunkt um zuzuschlagen
und die dinge an die erde zu bringen
mittlerweile sollte was eigentlich jeder
von euch klar sein dass der topinambur
ziemlich hartnäckig ist und sich gerne
überall aus preise wo er nur kann und
deswegen sollte man wenn man den pflanz
entweder eine richtig tiefe rhizom
sperre in den boden ein
wir reden davon ungefähr 40 zentimeter
tief wir verwenden stattdessen jetzt
einen mörtel kübel und werden ihn
einfach im kopf anbauen das funktioniert
auch richtig gut
ich werde jetzt ein paar löcher rein
machen damit das wasser abfließen kann
dann führen wir den pflanzerde und dann
zeige ich euch wie man die dinger
pflanzen
[Musik]
der pflanzabstand beträgt ungefähr 40 x
60 cm und wir pflanzen die knollen jetzt
10 cm tief
[Musik]
wenn ich jetzt den topinambur nach
draußen pflanzen würde dann würde ich
mir erst mal meine grabegabel schnappen
und dann alles schön auflockern so dass
die knollen sich richtig schön in der
lockeren erde ausbreiten können
und wenn da viele steine in deinem bett
sind dann sammelte jetzt auch als erstes
erstmal raus
es gibt mit topinambur nur ein großes
problem das sind die wühlmäuse die
finden den halt auch total lecker gründe
deswegen gibt es eine idee aus der
permakultur dass man die topinambur
knolle in siena gepflanzt weil die
hühner scharren das gefällt den mäusen
überhaupt nicht ich habe auch schon
beobachtet wie unsere hühner mäuse am
stück verschlungen haben das heißt sie
sind auch kleine mäusejäger und der
topinambur wächst in die höhe und bildet
einen kleinen wald für die hühner wohl
sie sich darin verstecken können und
vorgreifen gehen richtig gut geschützt
sind dass es also eine tolle idee wie
diejenigen von euch die vielleicht auch
ein paar in einem garten haben aber
natürlich wollen wir nicht nur umher
jährige pflanzen anbauen sondern der
einjährige gemüsegarten hat natürlich
auch absolut seine berechtigung
und da gibt es super viel was du machen
kannst um den fast genau so pflegeleicht
zu gestalten wie die mehr ihren pflanzen
und darüber spreche ich in diesem video
also schaue gerne mal vorbei wenn dich
das interessiert ansonsten gehe raus
macht die welt ein bisschen grüner
pflanzen topinambur die sehen uns am
samstag wieder